hi I'm Daryl Ducharme a developer
relations engineer for Google cloud in
this video we'll learn how Google Cloud
VMware engine can enable fast and
seamless migration to Google cloud is it
better to lift and shift or refactor and
transform stick around to find out
let's look at an international retail
company called fashional mode which
sells only the most fashionable clothes
available
being in retail they have to contend
with seasonal Peaks needing High
availability replicating data across
zones and other things companies like
this deal with
like the vast majority of sizable
businesses that have been around for
more than 15 years
fashion all a mode runs the majority of
their applications in data centers and
the majority of these applications are
running on the VMware platform but
they've recently decided to make the
jump to the cloud because they want to
lower their operating costs stop
managing their own data centers
modernize data analytics respond faster
to business requests and protect
themselves from the latest security
threats so now they've got to figure out
how to make the jump
unfortunately different people at
different levels of the organization
have different goals
the fashional mode c-level executives
are focused on growth Innovation and
speed they want fashion all a mode to
lead their industry and they see the
cloud as an enabler of that Innovation
so their goal is to drive the complete
transformation of their entire business
as soon as possible and invent new ways
to serve customers leveraging Cloud
capabilities
the it Ops Team on the other hand is a
little more cautious
their main concern is risk reduction
they want to keep downtime minimal while
maximizing existing I.T and operational
resources
common questions both teams are asking
include how fast can I migrate to the
cloud and how disruptive will it be will
we incur downtime how will my team learn
how to run everything in the cloud
what should I do with my applications
and why should I retire replaced rewrite
Etc so what's the best approach
Google Cloud VMware engine gcve
because fashionable mode wants to
migrate now and not over several years
and they don't want to incur downtime
nor do they have time to re-platform or
refactor their applications they want to
run systems and applications as they are
today so that they can transform over
time and many of their applications are
cots apps that they cannot re-platform
that's a lot to think about luckily
Google wants to reduce all that
confusion to do they refactor and
transform or do you simply lift and
shift
balancing the two often requires a
trade-off forcing leaders to choose
between lift and shift low risk and
effort and refactor and transform
innovation
the good news is that they don't have to
choose between the two they can do both
this is not like Neo's choice between
the red pill and the blue pill and the
Matrix they can have the purple pill
both
this is where Google Cloud VMware engine
gcve came in
Google Cloud VMware engine is a fully
managed first-party Google service that
lets them run VMware workloads natively
on Google Cloud
it is the VMware ecosystem they're
accustomed to running on Google
infrastructure supported by Google
Cloud's expert support team that means
we can offer some pretty cool features
including large-scale dedicated
architecture four nines of availability
for a single zone and a full integration
with virtual private Cloud networking
capabilities so they don't need to deal
with complicated routing overhead
also large node design coupled with
vspheres over subscription capabilities
lowers TCO by providing compelling
density per dollar and high
consolidation ratios
fashion a la mode could have their
VMware dedicated private Cloud running
in Google in under an hour with just
three clicks and be a part of a rich
ecosystem with support for VMware
tooling Google services and third-party
isv Solutions
gcve's shared responsibility model means
their team only needs to worry about the
management of their workload VMS and the
administration of VMware tools like
vsphere vsan NSX and hcx
Google operates and performs lifecycle
management of the underlying data center
compute storage and networking
components for them additionally gcve
lets them take advantage of the security
and DDOS protection of Google cloud with
fully dedicated infrastructure that's
physically isolated from the
infrastructure of other customers this
allows their team to put more of their
resources where it matters most
providing business value to their
customers
all customers who want to adopt the
cloud for their VMware workloads without
sacrificing the VMware platform's
richness and without sacrificing all of
the Innovative services that Google
cloud has to offer for infra and app
monetization can now do so with VMware
engine
Google Cloud VMware engine represents
the fastest way to migrate or lift
VMware workloads to Google cloud and do
so non-disruptively with a private cloud
in a public Cloud architecture that
gives fashion Alamo The Best of Both
Worlds choosing Google cloud and moving
to Google Cloud VMware engine also
provides a platform that allows them to
maximize the usage of their existing
Investments once in the cloud they
immediately began transforming their
current offering by creating hybrid
applications that enabled their business
to be more agile by using Google
services across data analytics Ai and ml
Network management and More in addition
fashion a la mode also modernized their
existing Dr backup and storage Services
as well with Google native and
third-party services so when we say both
we mean they could still take advantage
of the power scale and features of
Google cloud and they didn't have to
re-architect their applications rewrite
their processes or retrain their crew
that might be hard to believe so let's
talk it through
first we'll start with the lift and how
gcve allows for fast seamless migrations
into the cloud
the lift part of this approach
represents one of the fastest ways to
migrate VMware workloads to the cloud
without changes to their applications
policies or processes to a cloud native
VMware private Cloud giving you the same
on-prem applications and adding the
power of Google cloud services
gcve allowed them to migrate rapidly and
non-disruptively to a VMware private
Cloud running in Google Cloud retaining
existing networks if needed for a
variety of workloads including latency
sensitive or high performance apps
non-critical apps traditional Legacy
applications applications requiring core
based licensing and sole tenancy as well
as multi-cloud and hybrid Cloud once in
the cloud they immediately began
creating hybrid applications that
enabled their businesses to be more
agile by using Google services across
data analytics AI ml Network management
and more
in addition extending their existing Dr
backup and storage as well with Native
and third-party services the transform
part of this on the other hand allowed
them to modernize according to their
timelines by providing access to the
full power of Google cloud services from
VMS residing in VMware engine
right away fashionable mode was able to
use Google's AI ML and data analytics
services to start improving and testing
out new recommendation and
personalization systems while using data
Centric approach to find the versions
that positively affected their
conversion rates and Revenue
gcve is a first-class Google Cloud
compute citizen along with GCE and gke
it is a fully managed Google first party
service operated and supported by Google
and its world-class team with fully
integrated identity billing and access
control fashionable mode has a simpler
end-to-end experience with other
services
they access Google Cloud VMware Engine
Services via the Google Cloud console
like any other Google cloud service they
can also access other native cloud
services privately from their VMware
private Cloud running in Google Cloud
VMware engine once they lifted their
application to the cloud they
immediately began creating hybrid
applications that enabled their business
to be more agile by using Google
services across data analytics Network
management Dr storage and more
as they decided to break out into
containers and use other aspects of the
Google Cloud such as get Google advanced
security Ai and ml Big Data tooling they
were able to do that immediately
at the same time their team and their
devs started building new Cloud apps all
this without disruption to their
business we've covered a lot of benefits
of gcve but it really comes down to this
if you're currently using VMware but
want to lift and transform faster use
gcve GCV is a managed service which will
help you make your CFO Happy by reducing
the cost of everything that goes into
running a Data Center and maintaining it
plus the cost of time to pay people to
run the tasks needed to procure Hardware
rack and stack gear security and more
all of that is covered when you use
Google Cloud platform
it'll make your CTO Happy by allowing
you to scale up and down workloads as
needed like helping fashion all a mode
manage peaks in sales traffic with auto
scaling and offloading the management of
that critical infrastructure over to
Google
meaning their ceto can worry about
growing the system not keeping it online
all of this comes with operational
continuity meaning your devs and
administrators can use the same tools
and get faster migration and it'll make
your CEO happy because once you've
lifted your VM into the cloud you have
access to Google Cloud Cutting Edge
services this allowed fashional mode to
innovate with AI and ml to improve
recommendations
all of these benefits come together to
allow your team to put more of their
resources where it matters most
providing business value to your
customers
so if you're on Prem today but love what
gcp can do for your business follow this
link which will be in the comments below
to learn how to get started with gcve or
call a sales representative get one node
and pay as you go to try it out
that's all for this video thanks for
watching
[Music]
[Music]